and speaking of january 6 as i mentioned
committees gotten their hands on all
kinds of new events
new communications new text messages new
call logs
and
they recently
got information from ali alexander
himself the man
who's a founder of stop the steel helped
organize this rally you know this was
partially at least his brainchild
and ali alexander has revealed to the
committee that yeah i had communications
with several republican representatives
who some of them now say like oh i don't
remember ever talking to this guy
but alexander absolutely turned this
information over
to the committee
and said here it is i talked to these
people and the people of course were
representative paul gozar a text
exchange with representative mo brooks
and uh also
andy biggs of arizona although he says
he did not
actually talk to him on the phone that
was more of an in-person thing
uh
pretty interesting right so how do we
know aly alexander has given the
committee everything he has
well because that is actually what
alexander is charging in a new lawsuit
because the committee still says we want
your records we want all your records
you you've given us a lot right you know
we asked for these things you've given
us these things but
based on what you've given us
this is kind of indicative that you were
talking to people and so we need to make
sure that you're not holding anything
back
so alexander has sued the committee to
stop verizon his phone carrier
from turning over the rest of his
records
unfortunately purely legally speaking
here
i'm not you know determining alexander's
guilt or innocence in any way
but i will say
having worked with the best lawyers in
this country
for almost two decades now
the argument that alexander is putting
forth to protect his phone records is
about as weak as humanly possible
alexander is arguing in his lawsuit that
you cannot have all my phone records
because it contains privileged
information
you know my my my conversations with
religious leaders
my religious advice to other people
talks with my clients talks with my
lawyers you can't have that
call log information
or those communications because that's
privileged
that's not going to stand up dude
that's a very very weak legal argument
and one that court case after court case
has shown us
doesn't hold up anyway
this is not to release it to the public
right if it were being released to the
public sure you'd probably have an
argument there
but this is for an investigation for
investigatory purposes and yeah you can
absolutely be compelled to turn over
that information
you know you have very little protection
at that point maybe your communications
with your lawyers could not be turned
over
but everything else absolutely not like
you you have you're gonna have to turn
that over you can't fight that uh very
very weak legal argument here let me
read this from politico
per alexander's attorneys jonathan
mosley and paul uh kaminar members of
congress have been on an organizing call
with him in early january
several were invited but he did not make
attendance the lawyer says
they also said alexander testified he
had phone conversations with
representative brooke's staff about a
dear colleague letter
and how his activists could be helpful
alexander said in a sense-deleted video
that he worked with gosar biggs and
brooks to attempt to use congress's
january 6th session certifying biden's
victory as a chance to pressure
lawmakers to overturn the electoral
results
we four schemed up to put maximum
pressure on congress while they were
voting alexander said in the video
biggs and brooks have denied meeting
alexander gosar has appeared at events
with him but has not elaborated on their
relationship
so knowing that
okay and of course the quote from that
now deleted video
do you think
alexander should have to turn over his
entire phone records
is he being honest that look this is all
i have i don't want to give you the rest
of this because you know this is
privileged stuff
or
is there more that we don't know about
how much can we trust ali alexander
now of course that's a subjective thing
if it were me you know just personal
opinion here i don't think i would trust
him
i'm not on the committee i'm not a
lawyer i don't get to make that
determination all i can have is my
personal opinion of him which i just
gave you
so the committee
has a decision to make
do they
just say all right ollie if you're going
to sue us we don't want to get involved
in that whatever you've been a
cooperative person thank you very much
we've got what we need for now we'll
contact you if we need more
or do they fight it and say oh no we
think you've got something to hide
who knows where it goes from here but
honestly and this is something i was
saying since the early days of this
committee alexander should have been the
very first person they ever asked for
material from
i mean like i said he was the brainchild
of stop the steel you know
why was he not the first if your goal
was to find out what happened that day
why was the organizer of the rally not
the first person
you subpoenaed
to me that makes the committee look bad
that makes it look like they were on
some kind of political hunt
to go after other people first i mean
why was steve bannon
subpoenaed before the guy that organized
the rally that doesn't make sense to me
and just to play devil's advocate for a
moment
if i were alexander that is something i
would bring up in that lawsuit
so
just throwing that out there
but either way
if he has more information he should be
compelled to turn it over
if it's determined that he is being
honest then okay he shouldn't have to
turn anything else over
he's one of the few people let's be
honest that's actually agreed to go and
cooperate with this committee because he
says you know i don't want to get
involved in all this other stuff and
challenging it and sue blah blah blah
blah so
look
he knows he has everything to lose from
not cooperating with this committee so
maybe you do trust him maybe you don't
it's not my determination to make
because i'm not sitting on this
committee but i will say this in closing
here
i think the committee has their work cut
out for them to the point where it's
time to appoint a special prosecutor to
really take over this because i don't
think the committee is equipped
to keep doing this on their own
we got a wonderful bonus show coming up
for you we've got more talk about kovit
a republican lawmakers passed away
we've got donald trump and bill
o'reilly's rally and i'm fair and
cousins thank you so much for tuning in
today i will see you tomorrow and for
the rest of the week right here on the
david pakman show